in order to pass through Heaven you have
to go through hell in order to get to
the other side of fear you have to pass
right through it
brought to you today by Roka unlock 20
off your order with the code Rich Roll
at roca.com
[Music]
the experience of riding big waves it's
really hard for you know anybody who
doesn't do what you do to even fathom
what that feels like or what that
experience is all about we see the
videos and the images uh you know of
Mavericks and jaws and you know now you
know nazaree with the lighthouse and
it's just like so insanely dramatic but
I I would imagine being there like at
the Lighthouse watching would be an
entirely different situation let alone
the experience of like being towed in
and like what do people not understand
about what that is like to drop in on a
70 80 foot wave you know I think
everything is just turned up to a
hundred in terms of like sensory
overload when you wipe out on a giant
wave you know it's sort of like static
on a television at a certain point your
nerves can't feel anymore it just
becomes numb and you know the greatest
fear really comes from within your own
brain
you know that the fear of like how deep
am I right now am I going to come up
before the next wave and
um you know I guess wiping out in a wave
you have to do the exact opposite of
what you feel like you do most of the
time you wipe out you know there's an
urge to want to claw and scratch to the
surface like I need to get out of here
but you're going up against an
unimaginable powerful force that you
can't battle until it lets you go and so
you have to almost go limp and pretend
you're you know I guess the best analogy
is like people that get into severe car
accidents you know let's say it's a
drunk driver it's usually fine and it's
the people that are sober that aren't
and it's because they stick their limp
you know and whereas like in big waves
I've trained myself to the point where
when I fall I go completely limp and
it's amazing how flexible you get when
your muscles aren't you know firing you
know that they're not you know you're
just completely relaxed and I've had the
back of my hand touch my back and I
can't do that normally because my
muscles are what's pulling it over there
but when you're so relaxed it can just
kind of go all the way around and and
you don't get hurt but it's when you're
trying to like fight it you blow a
shoulder out you know or something
happens
um you get way more tweaks so I
literally feel like a tomahawking
starfish underwater just like you know
just sort of letting it happen and I
have a pretty good awareness of what is
around me surrounding so like let's say
a rogue jet ski is flying through the
White Water I can sort of sense it it's
weird it's like a spidey sense in a way
and I can put my hand up real quick or I
can kind of have a sense where my board
might be underwater based on how I fell
or you know where my leash is pulling or
something so I can kind of block it if I
have to real quick it's kind of just a
karate chop and then back to lamp
um and so that's the Wipeout portion but
like actually riding the wave the speeds
are insane I mean when we're riding out
at Nazareth I'm easily doing 55 60 miles
per hour
um and you're going over the shop and to
train for something like that that's
really really difficult because all year
long you're riding waves that are you're
maybe going 20 miles per hour 23 miles
per hour that's like being on a good
wave where you're pumping down the line
and you're flying and you know the chops
aren't the same whereas you know the
chops coming up a nazri wave are as big
as waves I was surfing all summer and
twice as fast
more than twice is choppy right so
you're hitting speed bumps the whole
time at twice the speed yeah and usually
and twice as steep twice as steep yeah
so like I can I do go behind my uh Wave
Runner and um get towed in on Flat Water
to test my equipment or I'll use my kite
to go really fast and kiting has been
kiting and windsurf have been sort of
the closest to get that sensation of
hitting big chops and bouncing and
having learning the control of it but
you know until you're going down a
vertical wall that's like
getting close to 90 degrees at times you
know it's like a completely different
sensation there's a free-falling feeling
and it's like usually your first wave's
like shocking I'm like I'm like how did
I even do those airs or ride the barrel
you know like my first few ways I'm like
I just feel like I can barely stand on
my board and then usually by the end of
that session or the next day I'm like
okay like I've I've kind of found my
comfort zone again here's a massive chop
why not try doing an aerial like Travis
Rice would do in Alaska you know what I
mean like because at a certain point
riding a big wave going straight can
kind of can to me it gets boring if
you're going straight the whole right
which is just like like pause for a
moment like that's insane because the
history of big wave surfing has been
about can we survive it can it be ridden
at all and now we've established that
you know these waves it is possible to
do that and you're elevating it with all
these Maneuvers and these Aerials and
all these other things that you know as
we said earlier we're really reserved
for small waves so you know how did that
begin for you to say like just to ride
the wave is is boring is like bananas
yeah you know I think I mean it's just
different for everybody but I guess I've
been doing it long enough where
you know I just see the potential and
the most potential for performance gain
in any sport that I participate in is on
big waves you know it's the ultimate
canvas I mean there's no reason why you
can't be doing doubles or triple flips
like Sean White would do in a half pipe
you know it's something that is totally
doable but it's like the Fear Factor of
hitting a 50-foot lip you know and
trying to fly through the air and it's
not like a half pipe where you know it's
going to be the same as when you come
down it's moving it's moving at 25 miles
an hour and so that's an interesting
Dynamic of these waves too and in
development of equipment but then also
trying to figure out how you can do
these Maneuvers because you're on a wave
that's moving 25 miles an hour and then
you're moving another let's say 30 miles
an hour down the wave
and then your board is experiencing
another 10 to 15 miles per hour of
hydraulic you know suction of water
being sucked up the face like there's
like another Dynamic of how the water is
being drawn off the reef and pulled
vertically so it's like there's so much
going on so I think you know
when you're hitting the lip of this wave
you feel the feedback you're getting
through your feet and you know what
you're seeing with your eyes you feel
like you're going much faster than you
really maybe are I mean you're going 50
miles an hour but it feels like you're
going 70.
um and so there's like getting
comfortable with the feeling of going
that fast and then you know it's like
it's forgetting the wave is as gnarly as
it is it's just it's it's you're not
even really seeing it it's behind you
most of the time so it's just focusing
on what's in front of you it's like oh
like I can land this chop hop this Air
360. 10 out of 10 times
every I don't know the last time I fell
on doing it on small way but when you
get on a big wave of consequence you
might second guess yourself and kind of
take off kind of funny and land slow and
then the wave could overcome you and so
but it's about like not focusing on
everything around you it's like allowing
yourself to get tunnel visioned you know
and then do the trick land and then get
the peripheral back and be able to see
like over here without but still looking
forward so you can get like a scale of
where you are and then it's like getting
tunnel vision again so you can like
pick apart the wave and I just look at
it I've said it a few times already but
like a canvas and you're the paintbrush
and you I look at performance over the
danger of the ride you know the
criticalness of the wave I just look at
what could you do like what would I
normally think of doing on this wave
right so there's this risk analysis and
you're sort of like this love child of
Alex Honnold and Sean White like you you
have the high consequences of like free
soloing but you're trying to do kind of
half pipe stuff on these massive waves
and one of the things that I've heard
you talk about that wouldn't have
occurred to me is is like the
relationship with space and time that a
big wave affords you like on a small
wave everything is very compacted and it
happens very quickly but suddenly on
this big wave you actually have like
time time slows down but also there's
more decisions that you can make and you
can you can literally yeah like sort of
chill out like that I've heard you talk
about like oh yeah now it's it's mellow
totally I mean one of my motivations to
become the best small wave surf I could
possibly be is the fact that when you're
saving a small wave you can't think
there's no time it's all off of kind of
like
going from maneuver to maneuver and sort
of like just going with it you know
you're not you're not really being like
I'm gonna slam this lip so hard and then
I'm gonna go do an error at the end the
best type of Surfing those waves is when
you don't know what's sort of happening
it's just sort of it's like your body's
almost kind of taking you and you're
watching it as a movie you know like
obviously you know you have to like tell
your body what to do but it's you know
the reaction time in small waves is
instant like you can't think about it
for too long otherwise you've missed
your opportunity it's just you're just
going through the motions it's almost
like muscle reflex of like training it's
always so much that these are the type
of maneuvers you would do in that
section and you take those cues and you
just do them your body just does it
whereas on a giant wave you have like
five seconds dropping in to really think
about what you're gonna do like I could
see a chop coming and it could be taking
so long and actually the perfect example
is
um and this is a crazy phenomenon that
happens at nazare is that you know you
actually when you're it's such a
different way to compare to like payahi
or a Mavericks where you know these
waves are more traditional like Jaws is
more like a backdoor pipeline it's a
real it's like a six foot wave that's
that's 60 feet tall right so it's a
perfect big wave the most perfect big
wave I've ever surfed and you know so
you can see everything that's happening
you see the wall it bends around you all
the cues are the same as a small wave
okay it looks like it's gonna Barrel now
oh okay this is a turning section
whereas Nazareth is like a giant pyramid
it really is kind of a rogue wave
because the biggest waves like unlike
Jaws the biggest waves break the
farthest out at Nazareth the biggest
waves actually break the farthest in
yeah it's like it's it is like a beach
break right it's a beach it's Ocean
Beach San Francisco on stereo yeah and
you see it you see that pyramid and the
white water is like right in the middle
and correct me if I'm wrong but you're
not even sure we which way it's going to
break right because it is these other
these these multiple waves coming
together could go left it could go right
and you're you don't even know well the
biggest waves out there what happens is
the swell comes in through the biggest
trench in Europe which is 10 000 feet
deep right to Shoreline this Grand
Canyon and what's the word that start
with a B the Symmetry yeah I mean yeah
the bathymetry which is like kind of the
Contour of the ocean floor it's very
unique and there's a ledge and what
happens to happening is the swell can
travel faster when it's not hitting the
continental shelf so you'll see the
biggest waves will be going past the
break they'll hit the trench they'll
swing in they'll do like a 90 degree
turn and they'll be coming straight back
towards you and then another wave that
had traveled over the continental shelf
will be coming and you know depending on
which Peak you are there's like a few
Peaks at Nazareth there's first Peak
which is right in front of the cliff
there's one and a half which is in
between Peak number two which Peak
number two is a giant right if anyone's
ever seen me surf Nazareth it's that big
barreling right that I got in in the
contest but anyway there's there's a lot
to it but the biggest waves they end up
connecting and making a rogue wave so
two waves come together and they'll
double up and they'll double in size so
when you're out waiting for the wave the
biggest waves aren't necessarily the
biggest swell it's like timing two
different waves coming in together I see
and um they break the farthest in and
they jolt straight up into the
atmosphere
um and they're so big and tall that when
they break the lip can't actually make
it to the bottom and I mean it's the
furthest thing from a mush burger that
way the thing is like a Avalanche pound
for pound will be one of the worst
wipeouts you'll ever take anywhere
um but I think just videoed and doesn't
do it justice and everyone I've talked
to that's gone to the cliff and and seen
it because it's probably the closest
viewing stage that you could actually
see a big wave you're just like it's
unbelievable because you see this you
see the the playing field right yeah
yeah
um but uh you know it's
when you're riding these waves you
definitely get the the sense that
um you know you do have a lot of time
but it's also moving really really fast
and what about
the fear piece like how do you think
about fear how do you process it how do
you move through it that's a good
question because a lot of my friends
cope with fear
um through nervous laughter and uh so
you kind of laugh off the situation that
you're in you kind of make it you're not
not you're not disrespecting what you're
doing by thinking it's like a joke but
you kind of like trick your mind into
thinking it's sort of like this is oh my
God what are we doing this is crazy you
know I think the old school mentality
which is probably much cooler was like
you know God put me on this Earth to
ride these waves and I'm here to ride
them you know it's like but yeah to me I
I couldn't Johnny Utah Vibe I just just
the old school I think those guys were
just cut from a Different Cloth they
were so gnarly and they were just like
old school grit like mountain men like
kill the grizzly and you know eat it in
their cave you know what I mean like
they're just hardcore you know like
whatever you know I think maybe just my
perception of them is so like big but to
me that was like their approach was like
you know you could die out here just
don't fall you know this is this is real
serious and that was just that was
pretty rad
um but for like I guess the way I've
approached it and my friends have
approached it it's been really like oh
my God like dude did you see that oh
it's so gnarly kind of a bunch of goof
balls going out and it's really funny
because you can see everyone's kind of
goofing around like not goofing around
but sort of like
they're kind of like like in awe of the
situation and everyone will switch right
as they're committing to a wave they'll
go into that like
Warrior kind of mode you can just see it
on their face it's like dude did you see
that wave that was awesome and it's like
all right go go go you're calling your
buddy into the wave and all of a sudden
you'll see their face just go they'll
just lock in and they're a completely
different person like completely
different and that's pretty cool to see
and then when they kick out they're like
oh my God that was so crazy so it's like
they just wait I think longer to flip
that switch to like you know that super
serious smell because it's hard to I
think it's really hard to maintain being
like
super serious like that but but still
there has to be those moments where
you're you're in the lineup or you're
ready to go and you have that there's
that moment where you're either going to
commit or you're going to pull out it's
sort of like a super intense version of
like when you're turning left into
oncoming traffic can I can I can I make
it through or do I wait for that car to
go like once you commit it's game on you
can't pull out right and well that's a
and you have to you have to like have an
appreciation for the consequences that
are healthy enough for self-preservation
but also that you know that that you
know thing that's pushing you to the
edge
absolutely uh and I think that's like
you know for me it's it's when I commit
it's a hundred percent commitment
there's like no backing out and I've
learned the hard way you know you try to
pull out and you don't go for a wave
because it seemed like scary in the
moment and then there's a bigger one
behind it you wear it on the head
um or you you like hesitate and you fall
while you're riding the wave and you're
like that shouldn't happen so it's like
when you do commit it's full commandment
but you know for me fear the way I
manage fear is like most people think of
it being kind of like a disabling sort
of emotion I look at it as sort of a
superpower and
as I I believe that the hardest things
to do you know if it depends on if
you're looking long term or short term
it's easier to do something short term
you know there's like an instant you
know feedback it's harder to do
something long-term you know fear is
sort of like you kind of got to manage
it a similar way it's the hardest
emotion to control because it's
overwhelming flight or flight fear um
like you first want to run SEC if you
have to you will fight but learning how
to be like able to turn on that fight
mode immediately
um if you can access fear and like allow
it to overcome you and then kind of like
take all of that and like compress it
and like just hold on to it for a little
bit and then let it go all of a sudden
it disappears and you don't feel it
anymore all you feel is like that's when
I start feeling six foot six in the
water you know is when I've sort of like
I've sort of like allowed it to kind of
consume me in the ocean in the channel
like before I'm out there or like before
that big wave is and it's like you can
do it through breathing you know it's
like breathing through it it's like
hopping an ice bath you breathe through
that kind of stress and
um and then that fear I think you can
really turn into something that you can
pull off things and usually you're kind
of questioning how did you pull it off
and it's like well the fear kind of
helped me you know it's like when I land
that trick I'm gonna freaking land it
because I don't want to fall you know
but versus it being like Oh I'm so
nervous I don't want to fall I'm scared
of falling ah you know you're like kind
of get weak in the knees it's like I'm
landing this and I'm not falling you
know it's like there's like the fork in
the road and it's hard to to manage
because sometimes you know you feel like
just depending on where you're at you
can't overcome that fear the way you'd
like but when you do it's the most
freeing feeling ever you don't all you
see is what you got to do and you don't
see anything else but you have to you
know it's like my favorite Latin
um one of my favorite Latin words is
um uh Akron which means in order to pass
through Heaven you have to go through
hell and so it's like that's like in
order to get to the other side of fear
you have to pass right through it does
that not also involve having a balance
like is this a fear impulse that's
holding me back or is this my you know
gut and my feel for my capabilities and
the conditions and the ocean that's
telling me Maybe not today like I'm
thinking about in free solo when out
like Alex starts going up and then he's
like yeah today's not the day and he
comes down like he knows himself well
enough to know like yeah I don't have it
totally dialed like that's not
necessarily fear as much as it is like
deep self-understanding uh yeah and I
think you know it's nothing is black and
white most the for the the whole
Spectrum there's a lot of gray areas
most of it's gray areas like black and
white are just the ends of the spectrum
and you know you I you need ego to be
able to like overcome certain things but
then you also need to kill your ego
to understand where that edge is or the
line and um and so but it's like it's
being Street Smart it's being logical
it's trusting your gut but then also
knowing when to push your gut feeling
out of the way because you know there
there's the gut feeling can be
sort of like mistaken for kind of that
fear and pulse you know like being able
to Signal discern the difference between
the difference yeah and I think our
internal resistance is a master of
trying to like deceive you and in that
deception really comes a lot of the
times like you gotta so it basically
comes down to you know if you're ever
interacting with somebody and they're
really emotional you get logical and
when someone's logical you might hit
them with some emotion you know
um and that's the same way with yourself
I think and it's like it's like when I'm
feeling kind of emotional about
something and like my gut feelings tell
me something I kind of run through a
checklist it's like I'm gonna be what's
okay logically is this possible yes
um
am I how's my strike rate for making
every drop
99 you know so you go through your
little checklist in a millisecond in
your head and and if it crosses all the
boxes you're like you know that's that
fear impulse trying to hold me back
right but then sometimes the gut feeling
there are times where you're paddling
and you want to go and then something's
telling you don't go like just like
something like in your stomach you're
just like don't go you know and it's
like but it's it's the difference
between like good don't go to to being
like really like no don't go like
something someone's telling you
something you know like you're getting a
message from somewhere yeah and you pull
back then you watch The Wave just
completely close out and annihilate and
then you see there's a bigger one you
just scratch over you're like man if I
went on that I would have like what
could have happened you know but so it's
it's a case by case and sometimes you
make the wrong call but then you learn
from it and you're like okay well I can
make that I know I can make it next
opportunity and how does how does having
one-year-old twins change that analysis
for you well never does it at all well
since I had them last April
um we you know I mean I had all summer
to sort of think about it and uh you
know I think there's two paths you can
do you can slowly kind of phase out or
not do something that dangerous but then
I always thought setting an example for
my kids to you know you have to I think
you got to follow what you love and and
for me as a father I gotta show the
strength of the family and I gotta show
the perseverance and the dedication and
the work ethic and you know I don't want
to be somebody that my daughters think
of as weak you know this is I'm the
example for them you know and uh and to
me it just it made me train harder I
just basically just did everything
better like I'm training harder when I
train I'm training smarter
um I'm much more meticulous I'm much
more focused I'm better at the long term
versus the short term
and you know there was swells for sure
that when I when I had to step into the
ring you know go into the pit
um where I was like uh like like it's
just a weird feeling you know it's like
could like could I could I not see my
daughters ever again but then again when
you get underwater you're you know
before you were only fighting for
yourself and it's pretty easy to give up
on yourself I think whereas like when
you're fighting for something great or
something more like your kids
you know it's like no I'm gonna crawl
I'm gonna do whatever it takes to come
up yeah you know I know they're like
ying and yang kind of thing yeah totally
and
um my performance got 10 times better
because of my kids I'm like and I'm way
smarter and more logical like in my
decision making like like I can let go
of like uh this wave my gut's telling me
not to go and then maybe I should have
gone and it's like all right well okay
the next one I'm gonna be out here for
12 hours you know I got another
opportunity it's like having the
foresight to to know that there's gonna
be more opportunities and not being hung
up on a missed opportunity because
you're gonna miss opportunities everyone
does it's just the nature of the game uh
and and to me though like coming out of
the season I feel like I feel so
confident and smart and better for it
like I just feel like everything I do is
better because of them without them
giving me anything directly just them
existing has made me
a better athlete tell me about your
training aside from being in the ocean
and riding waves
um what is the regimen look like I train
in the gym five days a week
um and it really varies throughout the
year sometimes it's more endurance based
so it's playing between being an
endurance athlete and then like having
really fast twitch muscles and right now
since I'm focusing so heavily on
being like physically strong feel to
handle a lot of the waves that I
encounter and you know being able to
protect my joints from blowing out or
I'm balancing the the I'm balancing
doing some heavy lifting with being
really light on the ground being able to
do you know you know flat standing back
flips doing
um air awareness sort of stuff to feel
to have that spring so when I land I can
on a big wave I can have the strength to
handle the wave I can have the strength
to handle the chop but I can also have
that ability to be like a spring off the
floor you know I can bounce explosive
exercises to improve your explosive
energy yeah
um but I would also think a lot of like
stability core kind of stuff totally but
I've been doing that since I was working
out at the gym with my uh trainer Scott
Sanchez since I was 12 years old and
it's yeah it's been yeah he's been your
coach that whole time right yeah and it
was like it would go like I usually you
would do three days a week and you know
the motivation would go up and down you
know when you're a kid you're like just
going through the motions and now you
know it's like I'm asking for more
usually I'm like oh can we do this this
you know like I think this would help me
a lot and he's like okay settle down you
know like hold up a little bit but
um so I do that with Scott and you know
we also like
um you know I'll ride my road bike or
mountain bike you know for endurance
types to stuff it's seasonal usually if
the waves are good it's like a lot more
on the water stuff but you know it's
like small challenges too that that I
consider training it's you know going to
the ice bath you know before a workout
which you could get the best training
effect
um you know for lifting you can actually
get or for explosivity so you can get
the best muscle growth from doing an ice
bath first which is kind of like
contrary to what it used to be but I
still do it before bed and that's really
important
um for me because it's like when I'm the
most tired and I just want to go to
sleep it's like up a nice path it
improves sleep though for sure it does
for sure
um and then it's like I make sure I read
every day
um I make sure that this is like brain
stuff right so it's like I'm always
reading
um I'm trying to learn
the native language of you know my home
which is Hawaiian you know I don't have
to but it's like I feel like it's a it's
you know learning a language is pushing
your brains you know and and then also
since I go to Portugal so much and my
toe partner Lucas chumba over there is
Portuguese and I never know what he's
saying I'm like I should learn some
Portuguese so it's like that's a rough
one it's it's actually come a lot
Portuguese has come a lot easier than
Hawaiian hawaiian's like wow really
tricky because it's not Latin based
um and so you know the words are like
you can understand the words but you
don't know the order of putting them you
know so how do you speak it you can
understand it but you might not be able
to speak it I think it's one of the most
beautiful languages but anyway so it's
like the training stuff kind of comes
down to mental stuff as well
um but then uh you know
like in on water stuff it's changing my
approach to like how I can maximize my
performance
um we'll warm up on the beach for eight
minutes and then that I made some
studying the lineup I know exactly where
the best ways so I know subconsciously
where I'm gonna be able to kind of like
hang out out in the lineup and then it's
a 20 minute warm-up from when I paddle
out
um I surf uh basically that 15 minutes
because it takes five minutes to get out
there I come in I have to watch for 25
minutes cool down be like cold and then
go out for 25 minutes and put my best
performance on and that has really like
helped me learn tricks fastest because
like I'll have 25 minutes on the beach
I'm just staring at waves watching them
and like imagining how I'm gonna do it
so you're really like focused
um but I mean yeah like everything
varies like the best big wave training
has to do one thing for big wave
training only one thing it would be
stand up paddling because it works
everything from the soles of your feet
all the way to the top of your head
you're constantly out of breath it's
endurance but it's explosivity as well
it's balance um it's maneuvering a large
board so I'll you know after the gym I
might go torture myself and go down to
the harbor and do a bunch of laps and do
it under time and you know that's
probably the loneliest type of training
just because you're just you're just
paddling and it's not fast you know
you're going Max nine miles an hour in
Flat Water so it's like
it's it's uh it's it's challenging in
that in that respect but
um you know as far as like breath
holding stuff you know it's pretty easy
to train your lungs um doing
um CO2 uh tables so like basically
getting less and less of a big breath
hold
um and then doing the same amount of
breath hold
um so the the same the shorter and
shorter excuse me the shorter and
shorter um breathe up to the same amount
of breath hold so you start at like if
I'm gonna do a three minute breath hold
for example
oh let's say I do at first two minutes
and 30 seconds of holding my breath and
then I hold for three minutes and then
the next one I do two minutes 15 seconds
and the next one I do two minutes then I
do one minute Thirty and by the end I
only have 15 seconds to breathe up and
then I still have to hold for three
minutes right so that short interval in
between is that is that like a typical
exercise that like free divers would use
to develop that or where does that come
from free diving is good because it gets
you it allows you to understand the
anatomy of how your breath works and and
how to properly breathe through your
stomach than through your chest and then
filling your nasal cavities and your
throat and your mouth and all that sort
of stuff and it's really good training
to do it doesn't apply directly to Big
way surfing because the best example of
wiping out and holding your breath is
Imagine running up a hill for 30 seconds
as fast as you can and then at the top
you have to hold your breath your heart
rate's High your you want to breathe so
bad you can't and so and but you have to
be relaxed you have to go limp you have
to allow it to like flush through you
essentially and so the CO2 tables are
really I would say freedivers might work
on longer breath hold like you know
people are blown away when they ask me
how long can you hold your breath and
I'm like oh longest I've done it was
like five minutes and that's just
through training like you'd be surprised
a lot of people that you know are less
athletic than me kind of just have a
day-to-day job that I've done training
with they can hold their breath for like
eight minutes wow and so it is trainable
oh it's highly understandable like
pretty much any average person in a room
you can get them to two minutes no
problem it just comes it just comes to
teaching them the right breathe up but
in your case it's really it's about what
happens if you get pushed under so
you're in a position to be able to like
you know deal with that but isn't it
just as much about like down regulating
your your like autonomic nervous system
so that you can figure it's like a hack
to calm yourself down in a in a like a
high stress environment yeah and for me
I I learn everything through I I'm more
of a physical learner and and so that's
been an advantage in learning how to be
comfortable underwater because
um I'm really aware of where my body is
in space When I close my eyes it's
probably been trained from being thrown
underwater like I know exactly where my
arms are and I can see I can see it with
my eyes closed essentially and so in in
learning how to go completely relaxed
it's a cue from my brain to to be like
it's okay whereas if I start kind of
doing any kind of movement underwater
that's like goes against being
absolutely calm my brain might start
freaking out
um and and that's why like
that like type of training you know it's
good to do like having I can't hold my
breath for five minutes you know like
that in the back your head but it
doesn't even matter what's important is
being able to
um be able to hold your breath for a
shorter period of time but with less of
a breath because you're probably getting
the wind knocked out of you with CO2
build up in your lungs that's that
burning sensation that you feel in your
lungs and being able to uh just like you
know be comfortable in the most
uncomfortable situation yeah and and
know like okay like I've been here
before I know I'll be able to like deal
with this totally yeah yeah no totally
and it's like and and your legs have
been working really hard because uh you
know I think
what people don't realize too is a lot
of the equipment is twice as heavy that
you're using you know you uh like the
board itself is you know 20 pounds 22
pounds and so trying to move that versus
something like and being able to train
on the boards that you're actually going
to ride on like those boards do not work
in small waves because they're too heavy
they're too narrow you know the tail the
weight is all in the tail but if you go
from surfing a six pound surfboard and
then you go surf a 60-foot wave and
you're riding a board that's 22 pounds
20 pounds and you're trying to do the
same Aerials you're just like your legs
the legs and surfing take the most
oxygen so kind of a a rule of thumb when
you wipe out on a big wave or any wave
in general is you don't kick if you're
going to swim you just use your arms
because their legs are going to use all
the energy yeah and at the same time now
we have these amazing Innovations in
inflation vests and anyone that has worn
one in big wave surfing has never died I
mean it's been close calls for sure but
it's that airbag you know we have CO2
cartridges and you pull it and it's
airbag deploys and you know we all train
so we can run the stairs of the highest
building in the biggest city but you
know we're going to take the elevator
first it Nazareth didn't you you were in
a situation where you couldn't pull the
core to inflate your vest when you went
down no I pulled it but it just didn't
really make that much of a difference
and
um you know there's that YouTube video
that I posted a while ago it's uh I had
my GoPro Max filming and you know the
the rule of thumb goes you know the
cameraman Never Dies so if I was like
man if I just film this whole thing like
it'd be totally fine and it was like
finding hope in a hopeless place you
know everything that could have gone
wrong went wrong you know all my jet ski
drivers like came for the rescue they
thought I was over here
but I was over there and you know people
commenting on the video where it's
always like why didn't you use a whistle
and I'm like I actually have a whistle
right here but I was filming and so I
just started yelling at him to let him
know okay I'm here it wasn't like held
saved me it was more like I'm over here
like hey hey so you know where I'm at so
when you come around but the problem
with Nazareth once you go in takes like
10 minutes to get back out right that
time I'm flushed out on the beach so by
the time I uh end up getting flushed in
you know it was like I was already good
but it was like I you know if you have
this camera and I'm like I'm about to
capture something no one has ever
captured before
so this is like really exciting I would
never put myself here on purpose but now
that I'm here I gotta film the best I
possibly can so like every time I got
wiped out underwater and I was like I
feel like I was drowning I was like just
hold on to the camera and all the screws
on the mount it was a custom mount it
was like loosening up I could feel the
big wiggling I'm like if I lose this
camera
on the last wave I am going to kill
myself like because I went through all
this to to lose this the golden shot you
know what I mean and then I waited like
five days after to look at the footage
because I didn't I wanted to like I knew
it was gonna still be a lot more tame
than what it looked like for real
because GoPros tend to make 80 foot
waves look like eight foot waves and you
know to my surprise waves looked still
pretty big but you know
um I didn't want it to distort the
actual feeling of like all right I'm
here right now you know like yeah you
gotta take it in if you're gonna go
through you might as well take it all in
we're brought to you today by Roka
glasses are not something you normally
think about as a piece of performance
gear which when you think about it is
kind of insane because you can't perform
at your best if you can't see well the
Geniuses at Roka basically rebuild
eyewear from the ground up no matter how
active you are or how much you sweat
these things never slip or fall off your
face they're super durable they look
awesome and they've got tons of super
classy modern styles to choose from I've
been rocking rokas for about four years
at this point I love them I'm a big fan
of the Hamilton style and gloss black
that's this Frame right here as well as
clear or I guess they call them vintage
on the website and if you want to try
them out for yourself you can do that
right now and unlock 20 off your order
with the code Rich Roll at roca.com or
you can click the link in the
description below okay back to the show
we first met at this uh event at Surf
Ranch which was it was like two years
ago I think
um and that was a event that was put on
by GoPro and it was an interesting uh
day of Surfing Legends like yourself but
also all these Mucky mucks from like the
entertainment world and the business
world like people from Netflix and stuff
like that I have a very vivid memory of
showing up early that morning and I'm
like like a below average Surfer at best
who has not surfed very much in my life
and I kind of told the guys there like
hey man like I'm I want to kind of
backpedal this a little bit like let me
just sort of watch for a while and get
kind of like comfortable with what's
going on before you throw me in and uh
they're like no problem we'll we'll
you'll go up in the heat in the
afternoon and then they ended up
throwing me in the first heat with you
yeah so I'm having like a panic attack
because the last thing all I'm thinking
is
if I wipe out and my board he like hits
Kai and he gets injured like I'm just
never gonna forgive myself you know so
uh luckily I did not injure you and I
got a chance to know you a little bit
um and that was a super fun day and and
I remember talking to Ramana and he was
saying uh
that uh like Mark Zuckerberg would would
occasionally like rent the whole place
out like he would fly in on a helicopter
or whatever with his buddies and just
like take the whole day there and I know
that like you're you're a guy who all
these billionaires like want to hang out
with and foil with and surf with and I
think you even like taught or went
foiling with Zuckerberg in in Kauai and
that just has to be like a among the
many surreal you know things about your
life that has to be strangely kind of
disorienting for sure I mean
um I when I started doing all these
things I just was a real product of my
environment and you know the motivation
behind everything I'm still doing today
is the love of just riding waves and
riding it however many different ways
and so when people that are on you know
a global level of influence like from
Mark Zuckerberg or you know somebody
like it takes interest in what I do I
mean I I think it just cements the fact
that what I'm doing is probably the
right thing like the funnest thing
anyone could do because
um you know it's it's something that I
get to fortunately do for a job and have
support but then you know you see a lot
of people who work you know their whole
lives just to be able to have the time
or you know the ability to go surf or do
other water sports like foiling and go
to different places and stuff um so yeah
when when like you know someone like
Mark you know hit me up once before he
it was kind of like wait how does he
even know who I am you know like that's
just crazy
um and it just seems like a completely
different world you know I always felt
like what I do is sort of outside of
society's bubble because you sort of
leave the shoreline and you're out in
the ocean you're in mother nature and
um you know there's just no sort of
rules I mean there I guess there's some
Maritime rules you know but for the most
part you kind of can go out and be free
like true freedom and
um that's always been my draw especially
in big waves because big waves are um
unmanageable but yeah like being able to
go you know foil and ride with these
crazy people it's definitely ins
interesting and also inspiring just to
kind of be able to pick their brains and
you know try to understand how their
mind works because mine works so
differently yeah yeah
and I I personally love meeting
everybody
um you know even if they may be
considered controversial it's like don't
really know somebody until you meet them
in person
um and it's really cool to uh be able to
just know that in my life I've been able
to meet all walks of life from you know
just the hardcore Surfer kid maybe the
you know Indonesian rainforest to like
all the way to one of the most
influential powerful people
um but you know generally I've had great
experience with just about everybody
because it's not about anything else
except for you know the whole time
you're talking about having fun and
surfing and boiling and you know riding
the wind and you know it comes from a
very pure place and it just feels like
you're on the playground you know right
and I think that's why a lot of people
are drawn to what I do is because that's
it's just about having fun at the end
yeah yeah yeah yeah and the opportunity
although you're worlds are so different
you sort of operate like a modern day
Explorer on some level
um and and you know from an outsider
looking in at your life it appears that
you have like this freedom to play and
to your point you know that's something
that you know most people maybe get a
taste of once a year or on a weekend or
like on their vacation or something like
that so there's something kind of really
alluring and appealing about that but
then to be in the company of other high
performers in different fields
um I'm curious as to whether like even
though the disciplines are so different
there must be common strains of of like
how do you do something no one's ever
done before how do you think about the
world and possibility and and Innovation
you know there has to be like parallels
with that I think the parallel is like
kind of that undying Passion For What
You Know Field you're actually doing
like for me it's like it's so in the
moment like right away for 30 seconds
um and how good can you be on the wave
like it doesn't it's maybe not the the
pyramid that'll last the test of time
but in that moment it's like the most
pure feeling but when you talk to
um or when I have the opportunity to
talk to these guys it makes me kind of
Wonder it's like gosh if I took a
different you know path in life in my
interest didn't fall in being uh you
know consistently athletic or
um you know it was maybe more in
whatever computer science sort of stuff
or just anything like Innovations in
other fields then I might be able to you
know have risen to the top in that field
because I feel like if you're always
sort of thinking about it you got you
have to force yourself to like give a
rest so that you could have these fresh
ideas but at the same time you're not
going to stop until you kind of fulfill
whatever goal or dream that you have and
you know when one goal or dream is
accomplished I tend to nearly forget
about the one I just accomplished and
it's always on to the next thing so it's
been a real lesson to sort of like
um reflect and understands like oh where
did you know where have I come from what
has been accomplished you know almost as
motivation like okay I can continue to
you know strive to do different things
and you know when I was a kid I always
thought I want to be you know three
things a world champion in multiple
Sports I wanted to invent the things
that I ride
um and uh there's one more it's slipping
my mind right now but I mean really it
was like if I could invent things that
could change the world I I didn't
realize that I would just be I guess
changing my world and subsequently maybe
changing some of my friends world you
know and then I guess you changed the
world uh with some of the equipment that
World Changers you know experience you
know someone who like like a Mark or
somebody who you know invents a social
platform that you know you can reach the
whole world and it's like well their
whole ocean experience has changed
because they're riding this hydrofoil
that you know I had a part in sort of
innovating because I saw it as a gray
area in the sports that I did and it's
always been about finding those gray
areas and um trying to figure out how
you could make something work in there
so you know it was like you had you know
this one time in surfing where the waves
were never good for high performance
things so being my goal to always be
high performance how do you make a piece
of equipment that isn't just
riding a wave and going straight because
the waves don't allow you to do more and
you know thinking on you know the
Pioneers before me and my respect is for
it like the Laird Hamilton's the rush
Randalls Dave Columbus that strap crew
from Maui sure you know their goal with
the hydrofoil for example was to ride
the biggest waves ever ridden and then
you know one day I sort of had an
epiphany after paddling between all the
islands my entire life you know for a
solid 15 years
um I was like how could I make this less
brutal and miserable you know it's the
ultimate test but you end up spending so
much time by yourself in these channels
these great bodies of water that you
know I want something High paced
something that's like riding a Jaws wave
and it's like well instead of riding the
biggest wave ever ridden on a hydrophone
could I ride the smallest wave ever
ridden which is these soft open ocean
swells between the islands
um that vary from six inches high to you
know 20 feet high but most of the time
it's like pretty small and so you know I
think in my path to trying to find
something really fun and high
performance that could fill that void or
that gray area and high performance wave
riding
um you know something kind of came out
of it that uh you know
inspired you know not just my friends
but you know people that
are you know innovators in their
respected areas to take it on and do it
and to me that's the ultimate reward I
could care sort of less about you know
if I'm known as the person that actually
invented it to the wider audience it's
more like wow it's successful because
everyone wants to do it so it means I
was right yeah my quest for wanting to
have fun I love this idea of of always
looking for like the third door or the
back door no matter the conditions where
can I try to find a way to innovate or
or find performance irrespective of the
conditions rather than just you know
sitting at home and looking at the
weather report and waiting until it's
ideal or perfect and then innovating in
that space and the impact the kind of
Ripple effects to extend the wave
metaphor like Beyond just athletic
performance surfing and and exposing you
know new modalities to everybody else in
the world I think there's a broader
conversation around just how that
changes the lens through which people
perceive what's possible like when they
see you doing things on big waves that
that no one thought possible or would
only be reserved for smaller waves or
seeing you you know Channel Crossing on
a hydrofoil or doing things that no
one's ever done I think it just shifts
it shifts the whole culture in terms of
how we look at our own limits in
whatever our you know sort of respective
field is and and that's part of I'm sure
the Allure or the magnetism for some of
these like Ballers out there who are
like yeah I see the world in the same
way like we do different things but like
what is possible instead of instead of
like you know oh you can't do that like
well let's find a way how we can do that
yeah
um no and I totally agree on that and
everyone kind of finds their inspiration
in different ways like usually a form of
resistance is a good thing for a while
just because it kind of forces you to
step out of your shell and I've always
you know been somebody that prefers to
take the back door versus like walking
in the front door because you know
that's that beaten pass but taking the
trail next to the freeway and might take
a little longer to get to the
destination but you know what you learn
along the way could be far more valuable
and
um you know as far as like Innovations
go and I can only speak on my
experiences it's you know a lot of the
way the equipment has evolved for me
um over kind of my career is based on
kind of going between different sports
and learning from different sports and
then taking that and applying it over
here and
um you know trying to not think
literally outside the box like sitting
there trying to think about it but
finding yourself in these situations
that force you to kind of see something
that might have been right in front of
your face all along so what would be an
example of where you saw something in
another Sport and then lifted that and
applied it to your world I mean on a
tiny scale but it actually evolves to a
much larger one
um you know it basically
for example what I've learned through
windsurfing and the technology that a
windsurf shaper is able to make on a
board has directly affected how my big
wave boards have been developed that are
very very different to what the
traditional you know design is and
there's nothing wrong with those
traditional designs but there's just a
certain way you can ride them and you
know as the sport has evolved into
bigger and larger waves and has moved
further away from the traditional big
wave breaks like Waimea Bay you know to
kind of the most intense heavy
situations at a place like peahi AKA or
a Nazareth you know there's a handful of
big wave breaks in the world that are
kind of in a different League of Their
Own due to the canyon and the bathymetry
of the ocean that allows these swells
you know it's kind of a perfect storm of
you know coincidences that allow one
place to sort of pop off and
um you know it you know on a small kind
of something that's affected me largely
is beyond just the boards is the fins
you know like I'll take windsurfing
Concepts
um which to explain like in surfboards
let's say you have four fins on a board
um the front fin is typically larger
than the back fin that's a very good low
end
um like speed
um producing concept
um it's great for smaller waves but as
you put it into larger waves where
you're hitting speeds on a 10-foot gun
um a 10 foot gun is basically that Rhino
chasing yeah surfboard
um you end up experiencing turbulence
and
um
the the water starts to boil around the
fins and that disturbance that
cavitation affects the rear fins which
is instability and you know the funny
thing about being a surfer is a big way
Surfer in particular but you know just a
surfer that rides all equipment is you
become a meteorologist you start to
learn physics not through traditional
methods of like math but you start to
learn the physics of how things sort of
work
um I would say maybe in more artistic
form and then you end up surrounding
yourself with people who could put
everything you're experiencing into
numbers and you can quantify it and you
could replicate it and you can adjust
and it's about knowing those Dynamics so
to get to the point you know having my
fins from my windsurf words that are
completely opposite to a traditional
forefined big wave gun I put the bigger
fins in the back and smaller fins in the
front to you know basically have the way
the water flows I watch say Formula One
you would think that formula one and
surfing wouldn't you know coincide and
there's two ways of looking at surfing
it's the spiritual Pursuit which I still
do I would say most of the time it's
going with your friends finding a wave
having no one else around no cameras no
nothing and living the dream right but
then there's the fun part of the
Innovations and with formula one there's
a lot of parallels aerodynamically I
mean air itself is just a really light
fluid you know and when you look at
being in the water and I'm not sure my
math is I'm not sure my math is totally
accurate on this but like for every 10
miles an hour of
um water pressure that you're
experiencing or that your equipment's
experiencing that's like 100 miles an
hour in air so let's say I'm going 50
miles an hour on a big wave my board or
my Fin's experiencing you know 500 miles
an hour of you know atmospheric pressure
around this fin so you know that really
fascinates me so I'm always looking at
the cars and trying to under they're
always talking about aerodynamics and
you know the parallel with formula one
and what I do it's like taking
technology and Peak athletic performance
and combining it and seeing what you get
as an innovator there's the innovations
that that you know you're pushing as an
athlete with your Maneuvers and the
Aerials and how you ride a wave and you
know turning that experience into some
kind of you know some form of Art and
then there's the technological
innovations which get super technical
and you know we see you with your shaper
and your boards do look different than
everyone else's and and obviously you're
a Red Bull athlete and I'm thinking
about Formula One and I was at I was at
the Austin GP last year and we're in the
Mercedes garage and they're they're you
know we're getting kind of a tutorial on
you know the the
um all the different kind of I don't
even know what you call them the foils
on on the car right like on the front
the back the wings and and how they can
pull them out and and you know shift
them by millimeters based upon driver
feedback to you know achieve a certain
specific result and there's just a
gigantic team of people and you know
however many hundreds of millions of
dollars behind the development of those
cars
um and there's so much that can be
learned about that aerodynamics versus
hydrodynamics and you taking that into
your discipline but it's a different
scenario because it's really this
intimate relationship that you have with
your shaper right how you communicate
what you want how that translates like
I'm imagining these Formula One cars and
in there they're in Wind tunnels and
they got all these engineers and you
know whoever else like dialing it in you
know I have a really good crew around me
and you know it's pretty awesome because
my shaper he has his own Factory it's in
the jungle of haiku on Maui you know
yeah in like a cannery or something
right yeah in a canner an old pineapple
Cannery and it's just it's I mean the
crazy thing is is you know it's it's
actually really cool it's sort of like
you know you go out into basically into
the to the jungle and you find this
Cannery and what they're actually doing
um technologically for uh surfing and
for actually water sports you know he's
he's been pushing the limits of like
just Carbon Composites and just you know
different Innovations for the boards
that I do ride that you know all my
boards are painted the same yeah but it
sort of hides the fact all the hidden
stuff that we've been kind of putting in
there to make it work to allow me to
perform better and you know if I look at
kind of you know two different pieces
you know there's the artist and then
there's the guy that's trying to you're
trying to engineer it and you really
gotta separate those two and have them
in buckets because if you kind of try to
go out and you're like overthinking your
equipment and you're not allowing it
just to do what you're not allowing it
to be the paintbrush on that giant
canvas of a wave sure um you know you
can distract yourself and get away out
of the the feeling you know like it's
about fighting the head and heart right
like how do you like how do you just be
present with what it is that you're
doing because if you're in your head
when you're you're not going to be able
to do the thing that you do if you're
thinking about it you got to do whether
it's like the physical training aspect
you know up until the day you have to
compete or you have to perform on you
know the 50-year storm or the 100 Year
swell
um
you know the lead up to that you have to
be able to let go and Kelly Slater
talked about it a lot when he you know
finally won his seventh World title and
you know subsequently went all the way
to 11 World titles which is just
phenomenal
um you know the there's a point when you
gotta and I think this applies to
everything in life is you do all the
hard work the heavy lifting and you got
to know when to like almost stop you
know and and let go and know that all
that work is in your DNA now it's all in
your brain you're not accessing it
because it's things in the water
especially in big waves happen so fast
if you're already thinking through the
process it's probably too late it has to
be like kind of ninja skills it has to
just come out of the blue
um and you know for me it's been really
like the moment I can sort of let go and
just have faith that you know all the
training I've done all the equipment
development we've done it's all there
and it's invisible but I I just have to
remind myself like if I can't see it but
I know it's behind me you know right and
and do you have a certain like type of
mindset training that you do to dial
that in or is that just wrote based upon
your whole lifetime it's experience it's
really really hard
um to let go because when you want
something so bad oftentimes I think you
could get get in your way you know I've
had opportunities to win you know
contests that I've dreamed about winning
and you almost like
and I wouldn't say it's like stumbling
before the finish line but you almost
try to control the uncontrollable which
is this Dynamic ocean you know and I
always refer to big waves because I just
think that's sort of the Pinnacle of
where everything is sort of like like
elevated you know everything is like to
the 100th degree of just Insanity
everything's moving faster it's it's
there's you know your life could be
threatened at moments um the equipment
needs to be up to par just the whole
Dynamics are just elevated right so it's
like but at the same time there is this
thing of luck you know the
uncontrollable part of the sport which
is you're only as good as wave allows
you to be and if you're not riding the
biggest wave you're probably not winning
and so it's like okay how can I like not
have to necessarily rely on riding the
biggest wave the whole time but how can
I perform and you know in that method
you could be like okay well I saw this
last big wave break at this particular
spot in the lineup because a lot of
these big wave lineups are hundreds of
yards and you know you might might be if
you're too stubborn and you're not
allowing yourself to kind of move with
the ocean currents since the waves are
always changing and in one day there
might only be four or five massive waves
there's big waves consistently but there
might be only four or five massive ones
so you know allowing yourself to let go
and be in rhythm with the ocean and sort
of like have a hunch you know a gut
feeling that I feel like I should sit
right here I can't explain to anyone why
but this is where I should be right now
and then the wave comes to you and
sometimes you when you don't try to you
know Force anything it just happens and
you like kick out of the wave and you're
like I couldn't repeat what just
happened because like a million things
like it'll you know big wave surfing is
you know a few things but one thing is
very spiritual you know if you don't
believe in a higher power you probably
would be quite convinced at the end of
the day since you're just facing walls
of water and so sometimes you do feel
like you know you're gifted away from
God and everything was meant for you in
that moment it was like this this
surreal experience that um is
unexplainable and I think that's the
draw to riding waves of consequence
because
um you know you're connecting with
yourself at such a high level that
you're you can't hide behind a mask of
any kind right I sort of look at these
giant walls of water sort of a mirror of
myself like and you see who you really
are in that moment and I've been
disappointed and I've also been like
kind of Blown Away of the person I've
become yeah it's a truth teller it's not
gonna you know put up with whatever
you're fronting it's gonna yeah be this
mirror who that's gonna reflect back
exactly who you are so it's humility too
sure yeah but you also have to have you
know confidence and enough ego to even
approach that and the experience and all
of that like I want to get into that but
you mentioned your you know relationship
with the ocean and this feel that you
have to kind of know where to be at the
right time and that's really what it
means to be like a waterman however you
define that and you mentioned at the
outset that uh
you know had you been brought up in a
different environment maybe you would
have excelled in some other field and I
think it's it's really hard to kind of
understand or appreciate your career and
the many things that you've done without
understanding kind of how you came up
because in so many ways it's this
unbelievably unpredictable almost
miraculous Confluence of all these
different variables that kind of came
together to you know produce this
individual that you are with the parents
that you you know were born into and and
the location where where you grew up and
kind of what was happening in that area
at that time matched with this you know
endless you know kind of energy that you
had and enthusiasm and curiosity uh plus
you know talent and and and you know
doing it as such a young person I mean
it was a perfect storm for sure you know
I'm a product of my environment I mean
it's sort of to me seems like my life
was you know out of a movie sort of
thing especially you know the earlier
days growing up because like you know my
Superheroes Were the guys that were you
know winning world championships in my
backyard at my local spot right multiple
Sports from windsurfing to kite surfing
um you know and then just across the way
it was uh you know Pipeline and and you
know there was just I was in the water
sport mecca for the entire planet and
you know in the 90s and early 2000s
pretty social media you know that was
just like it was the DVDs and the
magazines and it was always like right
where I was living and the fact that I
got to see my heroes first hand like on
a consistent basis where I got to even
know them you know or I got to be
introduced via my parents or friends of
friends and you know and then there was
you know the Mount Everest of big wave
surfing was in my backyard and you know
it was sort of you know our snow days at
school was when there was a giant swell
and our teachers would allow us to go
play hooky and we'd go sit on the cliff
and watch these guys ride waves of
unimaginable size and especially because
it was so new back then
um you know no one knew that you could
survive some of these rides so every
Wipeout was like a near-death experience
for somebody technology hadn't quite
caught up with you know the safety and
um and and it was all being invented in
front of me sure and so just in viewing
that it's like when you have Mount
Everest in your backyard eventually you
got to go climb it and you know I went
out there and it was it you know at 16
years old and I realized okay this is
like what I want to do but I had the
influence to do multiple Sports because
my you know Idols all you know invented
them you know or were innovating them
um and you know my first experience ever
riding Jaws for example wasn't by any
traditional means it wasn't on a toe
board it wasn't on a paddling gun it was
actually on a hydrofoil board with
snowboard boots and I was out there with
Laird Hamilton and Dave Kalama and it
was only us you know palm trees being my
fans you know swaying in the wind and
it's just like you know you see these
kind of like as a kid you know they
represented you know Superman and Batman
and all those guys and I'm like hanging
out there you know I'm like the new kid
that they've kind of brought under their
wing and you know one of the funniest
experiences about that was the fact how
I like you know almost or actually I
really embarrassed myself in the
beginning because I had been
hydrofoiling a lot but you know the
snowboard boots don't do too well in
salt water over a long period of time
and you know you know these guys take it
especially then they took it very
seriously because you know this is
pre-inflation vest which we could talk
about Innovations and stuff but
um you know you could you know you're
taking a 16 year old kid out there at
the time young kids weren't going out
there and I waited until their blessing
and their invite for me to go but I got
on the board and I was clicked into the
clicker bindings you know um the old K2
clicker bindings those were like the
ideal setup for the hydrofoil and you
needed those because the aluminum foil
every the kind of the whole concept of
the hydrophone was extremely unstable so
you needed something very stiff to help
control it through the board and you
know nowadays the foils are so good you
can just stand on it no boots no straps
even but I remember getting towed up and
the the soles of the boots cheering off
and me falling and this was supposed to
be my moment right like where I'm like I
join the you know the Justice League I
joined my heroes you know what I mean
and this is the litmus test
first five seconds I come up and they
just I'm like the souls are off and I'm
just free-floating and I'm about to get
towed into this Jaws wave and I'm like
so I just let go of the Rope you know
like right before and I could just see
the look of disappointment on their face
you know like Dave and Laird as they
turn the ski around they were looking at
me like like you could just tell they're
like why did we even take this kid out
here and then all I did was just lift my
foot and they could see them on my foot
and they just started busting out
laughing and they're like oh my gosh
it's crazy and so they threw me you know
Dave klama threw me his boots which were
three sizes too big at the time and I
ended up really towed into a couple
pretty big waves and didn't fall got
close a couple times you know just
figuring it out and you know that was
just getting a hat on the back from
those guys afterwards was really special
and that just sort of you know that was
the snowball that turned into the
Avalanche of where I'm now it's hard to
it's hard to understate the impact of of
Laird and Kalama and the strapped crew
and that ethos of innovation being
exposed to that approach to surfing at a
very early age you know and creating you
know kind of a shared respect for that
way of looking at the sport I think was
huge and just like yeah like being Jaws
in your backyard those guys are the best
in the world pushing the envelope right
there are you finding a way to
ingratiate yourself into that but also
they also represented a different
kind of
um
new culture in surfing because surfing
is a very kind of tribal situation
you're part of this crew you're part of
that crew this is cool this isn't cool
but at a very early age you never bought
into any of that like you're windsurfing
and you're foiling and you're you know
experimenting in all these different
ways on the ocean instead of you know
kind of
doing what most people would have done
which is like finding their their kind
of one affiliation and sticking with
that I think it's having the ability and
the foresight to kind of see where
things are headed to
um you know being able to understand
like if I go down this sort of path
um where is that going to lead in you
just kind of like it's almost like
playing a game of just wondering where
it's gonna go
um you know or like how much how much
room of for Innovation there is but then
the core of it is you know having that
undying passion that real love for it
like I could wake up and go every single
day without being phased not this never
would feel like a chore and
um I guess the traditional path of you
know when I was growing up there was
like two ways it was like one pass was
being led as this kind of waterman
lifestyle that strap crew layered
Hamilton sort of approach and then there
was the you know Kelly Slater Andy Irons
era the pro world you go into the you
know as a you know you you only
shortboard you only write a board that's
you know a couple inches taller than you
are and you know you do the local Junior
events then you do the state low state
level Junior events and then you go to
the Nationals then you go to the World
Juniors and then eventually you qualify
for the World Tour off of the you know
qualifying series and there's like all
these steps and you know the only way to
get sponsored or supported as an athlete
um you know is to do that and there was
so many times where like I was you know
kind of making a name for myself as like
a multi-sport athlete but I wasn't by
any means you know a successful athlete
yet you know like I wasn't you know the
sponsorship I had was like more flow you
know and it's like oh here's some
clothes sort of thing and I mean that
started but like to be fair I mean
didn't you get your first sponsor at
like 10 I did for sure and it was all
equipment and Red Bull 13. totally okay
so but I mean you know it's like it's
the culture it's not it's if you want to
be a pro Surfer you're on such an early
path of how you're supposed to do it
it's hard because we're in this social
media culture now where it feels like an
easier lift than it was you couldn't
have exposure without kind of getting
the blessing from you know the core
magazines like you had to almost be
buddies of a buddy or you know like just
be in with their In Crowd I think the
Europeans actually were the ones that
really helped jump start my career as
like uh you know a sponsored athlete
because everything that I was sponsored
for kind of pertained to going to Europe
and visiting and you know they were all
into windsurfing and stuff and these
alternative Sports and they liked I
guess culturally what these innovators
in Hawaii were doing
um and so I mean I just remember like
you know meeting with you know uh people
of great influence or agents or whatever
and they're like hey you got to stop
doing whatever you're doing and just
focus on shortboarding and maybe they're
right as far as I probably would be on
maybe the World Tour by now if I focus
on that one thing but it just didn't
feel right for me my parents had always
instilled in me you know self-confidence
and and and really you know taking a
step back and relying on my gut feeling
and like like what what's your heart
really tell you you can actually you
know there's like kind of that I would
say it's not even a cold spot because
cold sounds like it's not it's there's
no feeling there but you can kind of
feel that pit in your stomach when it
kind of can direct you one of two ways
you know and I feel like I'd always
listen to that sort of like feeling and
I'm like I'm not sure how it's gonna
work out but it is and just like I would
sort of fall into competitively being in
a certain sport for a while and then it
would just sort of take me like I would
I was in stand-up paddle racing and
stand up how racing looked like it was
going into the Olympics and we were
going through waves and I was way riding
I was winning world titles and the sport
you know for a period of time was one of
the biggest water sports on the face of
the planet and it was everyone was
talking about it and then as it sort of
declined I kind of like without trying
sort of just sort of drifted the
opposite way into what I would consider
the spiritual pursuit of my wave riding
which was riding big waves and now there
was a world tour for big wave varieties
like cultures catching up cultures like
this wave behind you or like right
you're in sync with this wave as it
starts to like you know break bigger as
you know the broader world begins to
appreciate kind of the most
multi-disciplinarian approach that you
were kind of innovating and perfecting
yeah it's like you know I everything
there's there's a lesson in everything
and I when I do these Channel Crossings
and I'm writing open ocean swells you
know when people think of a rogue wave
in the middle of the ocean they think of
this giant wave that's just breaking
right but it's a chaos of smaller waves
and when it's when two waves sort of
combine and it creates something really
big and that wave out in the middle of
the ocean might last only a couple of
seconds you know and then it just
disappears and but it turns into
something else then that's the really
interesting thing is like you know
energy can't be created or destroyed and
um you get to see that first hand every
single day with you know the way the
ocean moves and
um sort of that you know being able to
let go of that ride and move on to the
next
um that's kind of been like an approach
it's like okay like I rode this wave as
long as I could
um you know what's peaking my interest
now and you know oh there's like this
sort of you can sort of see the timing
of how things are going to evolve a
certain way it's like wow that sounds
exciting like this could go someplace
and it's not about like just trying to
keep your career afloat it's more like
you are following your passion the whole
time but it's it's the ability to let go
and sort of like allow yourself to kind
of go oh this looks kind of fun over
here and and wander yourself into it and
then you end up kind of looking back on
how everything played out like if you
planned it it couldn't have worked any
better looking in the rear view it all
makes perfect sense yeah yeah no it's
good to reflect on it and then like
learn from it and and like appreciate it
and it's a good reminder though on how
you got there you know it's like wow I
actually was able to just kind of like
get an opportunity seize the opportunity
realize that oh there's actually some
potential here and and run with it and
then you know see another opportunity
and just allowing yourself to sort of
like in a way feel it out I mean like
this feels right right now before
everyone sees it you know I guess it's
like trying to be on one of those early
Tick Tock Trends or something you see it
before it's big right and then as it
starts to decline yeah right yeah well
it's it's it's
it sounds to me like it's about holding
things Loosely like it's a it's about
like not being overly attached to any
one particular thing because when I
think about you as a young person
winning eight World Championships in
stand-up paddle the obvious question
well why didn't you just keep doing that
how many could you have won but for you
to then pivot to something else and tap
into that neuroplasticity that you
developed as a young person where you
were like you know across the board
experimenting in all these different
disciplines and trying to then apply
that in in new areas that's a level of
on the one hand it's a level of maturity
for a young person to be able to make
that kind of pivot but with that kind of
crazy success at what were you like 21
or 22 or something like that
um
it had to also change your relationship
with what it means to be successful or
or or or like the the kind of importance
of like winning in a competition context
like after winning that so many years
then you know what else is there to do
or what where is the real nourishment
coming from like what is the underlying
purpose that's driving you beyond like
victories I'm sure I mean sure everyone
experiences this but it's like the
constant pursuit of purpose like you
know and you could think really broadly
and you have a lot of time to think
about it when you're floating out in the
middle of the ocean between either
Islands or you know in between giant
waves or anything you know there's like
the great thing about going in the water
and doing these Sports is there's a lot
of thinking time in between you know
really intense exciting rides and
moments and
um you know I think it's like
having done so well in you know stand-up
hattling in certain Sports and and then
all of a sudden kind of going into this
big wave room where I didn't feel like I
was I was personally legitimate yet you
know it's like it's like wow there's
this real hunger to try to like I don't
want to say impress others but there is
that level of like proving yourself
especially to the chorus form of you
know Surfers you know culturally you
know hardcore surfing I mean it's like
it does feel good when you could paddle
out to line up and everyone's like oh
yeah what's up you know what I mean
versus being an outlier which I spent
most of my life being an outlier because
I was doing so many randoms like sports
that weren't considered hardcore you
know that lot has changed now just in
this next Generation because so many
kids now are they just do everything you
know it's just like you don't just
shortboard you actually just you foil
you you pick up a win sport like winging
or kite surfing or you know you just
kind of do it all and it's really cool
to see how that's evolved you know
because for a while I was one of the few
in my generation that was approaching it
that way and so and then it's like this
seems like okay I've climbed this
mountain over here you know this seems
like the next big thing like I want to I
want to continue to grow as an athlete
but as a person and you know what's
scarier than try to compete in big ways
then you know you have to balance
performance and self-preservation and in
order to win you kind of gotta throw
self-preservation out the door a little
bit and that just comes through
experience time confidence that you
could survive whatever scenario you end
up yourself putting yourself in and you
know it was a bummer because just the
landscape of being a professional
athlete changed like it it probably
changed slower than this but it felt
like overnight where you know there was
all these like tours and and you know
magazines supported it and you'd see
movies about the this and it was like
the storyline and when social media
really blew up it kind of like dissolved
a lot of you know these larger entities
of supporting a tour so like the world
surf League decided they no longer
wanted to do the big wave World Tour and
I'd come up runner-up on the big wave
World Tour and it was like right when I
felt like I had just sort of like found
my balance and I was like gonna be able
to go on a you know a run of winning
world titles in really big waves all of
a sudden it's like that opportunity just
evaporated it went into a puff of smoke
and and that was like kind of shocking
because I hadn't experienced that yet
you know it was more like okay get
really good in this one sport be
successful and then it was like oh wow
look at this this is like a new hot
thing it looks so fun like work on that
you know when World titles over here and
so you know with that it was like all of
a sudden it felt like wait I'm supposed
to
be winning world titles in all these
different sports like there was always a
plan you know like in my own head that
was the plan and you know when you don't
have the playing field all of a sudden
it just evaporates there's nothing you
could really do so I definitely like you
know felt lost you know competitively
for a while because I was like I could
go back but then at the same time I'm on
such a you know I'm I feel like I have
to stick with this like this approach
that I'm going you know versus like kind
of revisiting what I've been doing all
along
um it's like I want to go more down that
Innovative approach and then certain
events would kind of come along you know
and I would be able to ride a really you
know big wave and win a contest and how
important
is it to you that you're at a specific
event at a specific time where somebody
is judging your performance versus just
the constant Innovation and the search
that you're on to find you know bigger
waves and and newer ways of of
approaching those waves in general like
is that relevant or do you feel some
frustration because you haven't you know
been on enough podiums or had enough
kind of other people tell you that
you're a champion and this that or the
other I think it's just quantifying
um all the training you sort of do it's
like kind of like a contest is a great
way to sort of like have everything come
to a head and then like reset afterwards
um and and it's also like sort of
proving to yourself that you know you
can compete against the world's best I
think it's less about like getting the
approval of others so much as like when
I put on a Heat jersey I feel like I'm
pushed to a level that I couldn't be
pushed on my own in my backyard where
there is no like heavy pressure there's
no time limit there's like you know I
guess the art of the game competing
um I think it really pushes my mental
um capacity to innovate and to progress
because like all like kind of the uh
yeah you know I just don't feel it today
it's like no you gotta perform and the
finals are always going to be in the
worst condition so you have to be able
to you know as an athlete training
towards something you know it's like
okay the contest is in six months and I
gotta like in that six month time I'm
gonna train every single day and I'm
gonna be adjusting and and you're
already picturing yourself there you
know there's a lot of visualization that
goes into what I do
um and I can speak on that you know in
more depth in a little bit
um you know sitting on airplanes and and
like visualizing riding these ways that
you don't get the opportunity to ride
that often but like the competition
itself I go back to the drawing board
right after and I have all the answers
if I lose I learn so much and I've like
all all these ideas and Innovations I'm
like oh my gosh we got to change this
about the equipment I'm going to train
this way a little bit harder I'm going
to like do a little less of this kind of
training and a little more of that and
you know I'm actually going to do less
of that Sport and go on this other sport
like kite surfing you know so that I
could you know actually get used to
going fast all the time because I can't
go fast enough like there's just like
it's it becomes sort of like a little
game and and that I think pushes my
Innovation so I like competition because
it definitely allows me to evolve really
fast
um and I think if you did it like so
consistently you wouldn't have time to
be actually that Innovative you'd be
kind of just sort of like trying to rest
and recover between each event and
there's that's a different type of game
but like in the one that I'm playing now
where the events are so spread out
that's the draw Serta
um but
um that being said you know it's just
it's like kind of a teeter-totter effect
you know it's like uh it's like you know
the competitive side goes up and that
kind of fuels the the Innovative side
and then it's like kind of you know
you're kind of going up this ladder you
know but it sounds like the the the the
animating Force like your motivation is
really internal versus external like the
competitions
create a situation where you're trying
to challenge yourself against yourself
to be the best as opposed to I need to
beat this guy or be better than this
other person on this day it's just an
opportunity for you know a peek beyond
the typical Peak to you know reach a new
level in what you're trying to
accomplish yeah I know every World
Championship or every competition I've
ever won I don't even know what anyone
else is doing I'm like look so Inward
and I and I just I have my game plan and
I fall and I do it or I have like ABCD I
have like a ton of scenarios that I
could play with I you know and then you
also have to you know let go at a
certain point and allow things to happen
the way they're gonna happen but you
know it's every competition it's like I
don't even I'm not even thinking about
you know who I'm competing against
because I just figure if I can do my
best performance
um you know I I train so if I do my best
performance I should win no matter what
you know whether it's a race you know
endurance Style or if it's like kind of
fast twitch you know high performance
tricks you know it's like if I do my
best writing I shouldn't have to worry
about what someone else is doing and so
that's kind of like my training
mentality uh and and when I do that it
it seems to like when I do it properly I
win you know and it's like it's almost
going like God that felt kind of easy
and it's like no no offense to let's say
the other people I'm competing against
but it just means that I kind of did all
the hard work the right way because you
can work hard and actually like just
spin your wheels in the mud so it's
about being smart and working hard
um and you know for me working hard in
my brain might be like I'm gonna go surf
10 hours I'm gonna just lift weights I'm
gonna you know do whatever it takes and
you know that letting go is being like
Oh okay I'm only surfing for 25 minutes
today because that's gonna drive me
absolutely nuts that's the Heat and in
most competitions you might only have a
25 minute heat in a day and what can you
do in 25 minutes you come come in with
an appetite and the rest of the day
you're visualizing it and your brain
doesn't know the difference between
doing it in real life and doing it in
your mind and so that appetite of
actually doing some the sport less but
then thinking about it all day you
actually get more performance benefits
and you actually get better quicker than
if you just went and came in sort of
exhausted and the last thing you want to
do is think about what you just did it's
like I want I want to numb my brain with
watching a TV show or or something you
know it's like so always keeping that
little bit of an appetite has been like
pretty critical to like
um progressing really fast you talked
about like how much you learn when you
fail and you lit up like a Christmas
tree like I feel that's a really healthy
relationship with falling short or
failing and and you know looking at it
as an opportunity to learn and get
better yes you win but if you if you do
fail then that's the opportunity right
yeah often winning feels like a relief
um you know it feels really good but
that that moment that euphoric I mean
it's all worth it you know to win that's
the best feeling ever but that that
feeling only lasts
I think that day for me you know it's
like you're in that moment you're like I
can't believe I did this I I just how
did this happen like you're trying to
rerun everything in your head like could
I do it again you know like especially
something you've worked really hard
towards
um and that's like you know you look to
for me it's like looking up to the
clouds and you're seeing kind of the sun
reflecting off of it in the ocean and
you feel very present in that moment and
you feel very grateful gratitude it's
like okay like I want this like yes I'm
on the right path like this everything's
working out and then the next day it's
like you almost feel dull like the the
dopamine is like dropped down the
adrenaline is gone and you're like I
think it's almost harder to kick start
you know actually you can kind of like
rely on it too as motivation like yeah I
want so I can I gotta keep training to
win I'm ahead of the game but when you
lose
the hardest is that day it feels like a
sharp knife you know between the ribs
you know you're just like it just stings
really bad and you know sort of that I
wouldn't say anger or anything but just
sort of like being sent back to Ground
Zero when everyone was telling you
you're so great you should win
everything and then you just don't win
and you're just like feel like an idiot
right now and you're like what can I do
to not ever be in this situation again
because you know and you want to just
avoid pain at all costs you know no
matter how gnarly you are you have to
sort of confront fear and pain and um
and and so it's like okay like I just
get really like analytical and I start
writing things down and I start making
plans and I over analyze everything and
then my brain starts spinning out and
then I like pull everything in and I
condense everything that I thought I
could do better and I make it something
that I can have an achievable win every
single day so it's like you have I set a
goal that's outlandish and maybe
impossible or to what I think at that
moment and then I have like maybe a
couple more goals in between like like
targets to hit and in between that if I
can't if those targets feel too Grand
and big I work on the smaller ones to
the point where it's like getting out of
bed and just being like I'm gonna take
an ice bath this morning it's the least
thing I want to do but I'll feel like a
champion if I like force myself to sit
in cold water just mentally you know and
it's not it's just having like goals
that you could sort of accomplish so I
feel like yeah I've if the losses have
led me somewhere much greater than if I
was just consistently winning I think
but that being said I'd rather
consistently be winning who wouldn't
right
um yeah like I love that that very
strategic approach you know when you
think of Surfing you think about you
know the Soulful kind of relationship
with the ocean and and you know you
mentioned you know spirituality in a
higher power and certain and like being
able to kind of feel your way into what
you should be doing
um and all of that is absolutely crucial
especially when the stakes are as high
as they are with what you do
um but
on top of that you're bringing a whole
new like level of like structure and
conscious intentionality to and strategy
to like how you're approaching not only
you know what you do every day but the
broader picture of where you want to
take your career and then bringing in
like a level of athleticism and and
training that I feel like is new or
somewhat unusual in the world of Surfing
like to try to elevate it you're
approaching it as a professional athlete
in a way that maybe isn't part of the
Real the full history of of Surfing so
you know how did that kind of come about
and what does that like look like on a
day-to-day basis when you're home in in
Maui well I think when I'm home in Maui
it's a perfect balance there's like kind
of a Harmony between like the going to
the places you're not allowed to sort of
film you know and you just go with your
buddies and you're like in this
beautiful place that people save you
know their whole entire lives to go
visit and you know you pinch yourself
you know you're just at this this
remarkable place but then at the same
time I got like I got the motivation to
to go to the factory to go work on the
equipment with you know my team go
design hydrofoils go work with my sale
designers
um you know go to the gym you know break
down everything that I need to do
physically to become something and you
know a contrast would be like here in
Los Angeles right now
there's no waves or real conditions you
know and I just came from Maui my point
of being here is obviously like
sponsorship related but then also
training related and you know when I get
here I get so excited and motivated like
oh my gosh this is I want to do this I
want to do that and like how can we do
it and it's the real technical side of
things and and then when I like I'm in
Indonesia you end up like sitting there
and it's just so quiet and just perfect
peeling waves and it's like like I don't
want to worry about anything else so
it's like those two contrasts I think
it's really important to have a healthy
balance of like going someplace where
it's just about like Innovation progress
pushing yourself like here in LA and
then going to somewhere like Indo where
it's the exact opposite where it's about
connecting with yourself so that you can
you know I guess it's like being less
the designer and more of the artists you
know like allowing things to happen not
forced because it'll look it won't look
right on the wave but allowing it to
come naturally so you're like in a
barrel it's like instead of grabbing my
rail with my right hand and I'm backside
I'm going to grab with the other one I'm
going to look back in the tube you know
it's like thinking Jerry Lopez thinking
Zen sort of thing and and then when I
come to my eye I feel like I it's the
perfect place in the world for me to
live because it's like Indonesia in the
sense that we have amazing conditions
beautiful landscape all that there's
like the spiritual aspect to Hawaii and
and all that and then there's also you
know the highest Tech equipment that I
could possibly ride is being made in my
backyard you know it's all there you
know like Space Age materials are there
and it's in the most you know so it's
like those sort of things like finding
that just finding balance is really
important um obviously so and that's
hard it's like it's always shifting and
most recently you know I've kind of
challenged myself daily because there's
the hardest challenge for me you know
throughout the year might be like
you you know you're at your most relaxed
this is when it usually happens you're
at you're least prepared you know
because there's like training is never a
constant Rising line it's an up and it's
a down you're tired and then you know
it's a kind of fall on a chart if you
just picture that and
um you know then you get a call it's
like Nazareth and Portugal is going to
be the biggest swell ever and you're
thinking God the biggest Soul ever means
like a hundred feet yeah and you know in
order to go play the game at azray
you're gonna get absolutely obliterated
no matter how good you are because it's
a beach break it's it's a wave that's
unrelenting and you know it's there's no
safe place there's no Channel you're in
the pit you know you feel like a
gladiator and Thunderdome and they
release the the lion and you have to
like
not you kind of got to just try to
survive the entire time you know and
perform in between so that being said
you get on an airplane from Hawaii it
takes 24 hours to get there no matter
how good you sleep on an airplane it's
not good enough you get there jet lagged
the day before the entire flight you
were thinking about could this be my
last airplane ride I've ever been on you
know so you're like trying to enjoy the
amenities
and uh and so you land get in a car
drive to Nazareth and you like look out
and it's already like 50 feet and it's
like it's gonna be twice as big tomorrow
and you're just trying to like just so
loopy you know pound a Red Bull and be
like okay let's do it you know and just
like take like the jet lag doesn't exist
you know you almost like will it out of
existence and you go out there and ride
it so like
um sort of get to the kind of the meat
of what I'm trying to say it's it's
about being I'd say
adaptable in in the moment and so I come
home and you can't you can find those
sort of challenges but then you're at
home too so like I have two kids I you
know have a homeowner responsibility I
gotta work in my yard you know I gotta
do stuff for my wife and stuff and so I
can't go climb my 10 000 foot Haleakala
Mountain for all day you know it's like
all right I'm gonna go do my training
for a couple hours come back hang with
the kids you take some weight off my
wife so she can go do stuff and you know
that sort of thing and so it's like how
could I like challenge myself and it's
like what am I most consistently
comfortable doing or what what is almost
feels like a habit and can I break that
breaking it yeah just breaking the habit
like the ice bath example just to enter
do a pattern interrupt to always pattern
interrupt yourself to be out of your
comfort zone it's like you you're tired
you want to just put on the TV and watch
something you know at the end of the day
it's like no I'm gonna read striking
thoughts the philosophy of Bruce Lee you
know I mean which is like very
philosophical and very like you know
it's very interpreted by you know your
own perception of where you are in your
life and so it's like doing stuff that's
gonna like and that's not hard to do but
it's like breaking that something that's
easy so the idea being that you're kind
of preparing yourself mentally to be
adaptable because you have to in surfing
you have to rise to the occasion and you
never know when the occasion is going to
present itself it's very different than
being an Olympic Athlete okay I know the
Olympics are going to happen on this day
everything goes into being as ready as
you can on that day and you know that
day for you could be any day so you have
to be in a constant state of relative
preparedness for when those
opportunities arise and to navigate the
discomfort of it not being ideal exactly
and and I hold my standard
um mentally to be like if I were to
fall off about in the in between the
islands you know like where I can't see
either Island but I know a general
direction I I want to always have the
confidence that even though I'm not like
an Olympic Swim or anything I could
easily just swim to shore like the you
know it's like not even a question you
know so it's like holding yourself to a
standard
um and and you know when I sleep that's
when I get to relax and then when I wake
up it's like until I'm not trying to do
something that you know could be death
defying and I can really relax but I
find my purpose and my happiness really
comes from kind of being on that edge
constantly I really feel centered and I
feel confident in myself and feel like
I'm a better husband and father and a
better friend when I really feel like
I've you know you know I am scared of
something but I'm on the quests of
accomplishing it right so the edge how
are you defining the edge then in that I
think you know it's like just in
anything you can probably overstep
there's I've my biggest training problem
is over training you know where you just
like zap yourself flat and it's the most
frustrating thing because then it takes
like a week to come out of or a couple
weeks maybe to come out of like training
too hard so it's like the fear of not
being able to do enough in a short
amount of time you know like I'm 30 and
I'm in the prime of my career and uh you
know I I'm still super young but you
know I realize that life is super short
and every single day I wake up I feel
like I need to I have a responsibility
or not even responsibility but maybe an
internal pressure to just want to be
accomplishing things and there are all
those times you gotta just like enjoy
the little things and just relax and um
you know the kids my one-year-old twin
daughters
um you know have really taught me that
you know being able to just come like
all the way back down to the core of
what's important and just playing with
them you know on the carpet and like
just making stacking little blocks and
having them knock it over you know it's
like
it's so easy to get so wrapped up in you
know the career and the ideas and where
we want to go and how big we want to
become and you know you don't want to
stop because you feel like you stop you
know you're not going to get any better
and I've had times where I've taken like
three days off just knowing that okay
I'm kind of on that edge of over
training and the the less the farther
the longer I ended up spending away from
what I was trying to accomplish the
easier it came shorter and I was like
what is it because I'm just thinking
through it and my body's not being
attacked it's weird how it works that
way and it's just like so
counterintuitive to me it's like I my my
thought is like work hard you know get
there but it's like there's there's
intricacies and it's like it's like
racing a car around a circuit you know
it's like you're not pedal to the metal
the whole time you know you're lifting
and you're pressing and you got to know
when to do that and somebody who can
dance the dance is going to be able to
get around the track the faster yeah you
can't it's not a success isn't a
function of pure will you know applied
forcefully like it is that dance right
and you have this restlessness and
relentlessness and focus and all of that
like you're very committed and driven
um but then there is that Letting Go
part how do those two things like
interact with each other and also you
know because what you do involves these
insane Peak experiences it's almost like
uh you know Special Forces operator
being deployed into you know some kind
of very intense you know overseas
situation and then coming home where
life is really calm and normal and a lot
of those people have a difficult have
like difficulty you know kind of
adapting or adopting or trying to merge
those two worlds like that hedonic shift
so does that come up for you do you have
issues with like
you know always feeling the pull to be
out like going to the next level and
achieving that like dopamine Rush that
you get with those things oh my gosh how
does that work when you're just at home
and it's flat and you got kids waking up
in the middle of the night it's like
sometimes I do feel like a wild animal
being domesticated but it's like I think
the the the the greatest
the greatest of all time have always
been no no how to like they're so
confident in how good they are and what
they do that they're they're able to
step in and out of that door like a
light switch you know be able to turn it
on and turn it off and that's something
that I'm learning and navigating you
know being powerful enough internally to
be able to turn on when you need to and
then turn off and I think that's just
that's the ultimate that's kind of the
quest all Warriors go after and we live
in a different era where being a warrior
isn't necessarily going to war and
battling I mean that's the gnarly thing
I think you could do but it's not like
you're a samurai somewhere or a
gladiator it's it's a little different
but I mean I would say the the
um kind of like
that tribal nature that's built into our
DNA you can still feel that and so you
find different ways to sort of cope with
it like to me it's like riding that big
wave and I never understood it because
like when I was first getting into big
waves it took me about like 13 years to
get over my fear of riding big waves
where it was like by the in summer I
would be like yeah I'm so excited to
ride big waves but the big waves weren't
there so it wasn't scary and then the
big ways of coming I'd be like oh I
can't wait for summer because this is
too scary this is so gnarly like
everybody you were like you barely had
reached puberty at that point no no for
sure but I mean literally it took me
from 16 years old like you know 13 years
like only a couple years ago did I
really feel like it was more of a a
canvas and less of like uh oh my God I'm
gonna die you know
um and and so I you know I remember you
know Laird had some very sick movies
back in the riding Giants and they were
always very dramatic and I loved it
because it felt like you were you know
living in a movie and uh and he was like
you know it'd be like if you were a
dragon slayer and there was just no more
dragons to slay and I was like so it was
a sick quote yeah it was pretty dramatic
and I kind of get it because like now I
get sort of get it because like just as
you get momentum in riding big waves and
the opportunity was there if you see a
big wave the chances are it won't be
there tomorrow and it might not be there
for a year or you know maybe in 10 years
it might not be the same way it was so
got to take those opportunities as they
come and all of a sudden you go through
the entire winter and you know I'm you
know on land I'm five foot eight but on
you know on a wave I feel six foot six
you know I feel like I can grow like
that's just my place where I
I lock in and
um and and you know that being said you
have all summer and you just feel like
oh where did it go you know like all of
a sudden that you can't get anything
that's close to that and uh you know and
if you can't find a way to process that
in a healthy way you're gonna have
problems yeah and I think a lot of
people like you know can get I think
arrogance can get you know kind of
misinterpreted with them not being nice
it's just more that they're just this
grumpy old bear you know and uh or like
in the past you know people turn to you
know substances and you know abuse that
because it was like a high and you're
just like this adrenaline junkie and to
me it's like always been channeled I've
been very lucky I Channel it into my
other sports but now that you know I've
had an entire year to like really become
a father and stuff I'm just channeling
it into you know my kids and and like
and it's a different way it's not the
same way it's it's like being just there
and just and being a good father and
being a good husband and and it's like
striking that balance that ultimate
balance but then you know still being
able to find things throughout the day
that are going to allow me to kind of
like sink my teeth into something for a
second
um and it's like like the little
challenges and that's why it's like you
know what's a habit that's you know some
habits aren't bad habits it's just it
just is what it is you know and so you
know breaking those is just it's just a
challenge like I so badly want to go
what to do ever with this thing I want
to look at my phone at this time
whatever and that's something everybody
could do right we all have our little
ruts or our habits that we know like
they're not necessarily bad but they
kind of just keep us stuck in a certain
mode right and they're like develop that
muscle or that habit of oh here's an
opportunity I can like not do that and
do this other thing that isn't
necessarily hard but that Interruption
like if you are in the process of always
doing that I think that's really
powerful to kind of help rewire your
brain for sure
um
no it's it's it's really uh there's
always there's a lot to work on
constantly you were talking about like
you know the various kind of roles and
responsibilities you have like as a as a
surfer there's the technician and
there's the artist and there's the
performance piece
um but there's also
the there's the Family Guy
um but there's the business of of Kai
Lenny right and and capturing everything
on video like is is part of that it's
part of your job so on top of trying to
innovate and go to the next level
in the sport you're also you know
managing cameras and being your own kind
of like one-man production crew and then
behind you you've got Red Bull media
house and the you know life of Kai
series and how does all of that you know
the kind of the entrepreneurial side of
what you do uh how do you
compartmentalize that or or make all of
that work so that it's not you know
infringing on you know the core of the
performances you're trying to get out of
yourself yeah in the sport it's all
about the feeling and having holding a
camera or filming something takes you
out of that which can take away from
your performance so like you said
compartmentalizing it is really key like
knowing
being able to essentially like be really
into doing the filming and like being in
front of the camera and like filming
yourself you know because it's part of
the job like being really good at but
when you put it down being able to just
forget about that and just get back into
like the pureness of what you're doing
that is like it's a hard balance to do
because a lot of times like I might be
going out and if we're filming something
I might be thinking oh I should I gotta
do this because this would look really
good versus like doing something that I
would naturally do
um but that being said uh you know I the
third thing that I forgot to explain
earlier you know is like three things
that I always wanted to do as a kid was
be a multiple world champion in sports
um I wanted to be an inventor and so
I've kind of accomplished those two
things where it's like innovating what I
ride and inventing new ways to ride in
the ocean and the third thing was
filmmaking like I always loved film and
and like you know my life felt very
cinematic as it was but like I loved
movies it was always inspiring and
um to me it was less about like trying
to
brag about what I do and how great I am
you know I find that sort of irritating
it's more like sharing what I'm doing in
the experience I'm doing it and
hopefully if someone can be inspired by
what I'm doing to do anything you know
they are because I'm heavily inspired by
a lot of people that do incredible
things I'm like oh my God that was so
sick like that's a great idea I want to
do that just to do it but like that's
like the whole idea behind the life of
Kai series and you know to have the
support of Red Bull it definitely it's
like capturing what my life is like in
this moment and you know hopefully
people find it entertaining but I think
most importantly it's like I want to
share the crazy experiences I have that
you know no one would be willing to
capture by myself and we have this
conversation with you know all the time
and with my brother especially who also
serves really big waves Ridgeline he um
we talk about it's like we want to film
uh on these big waves stuff that no you
know cinematographer would ever go to to
you'd take an athlete but no athlete
would ever want to take a camera so it's
like finding another gray or it's like
gosh I without you know 99.99 of people
will never ride a big wave
um so bringing that feeling and
experience to them that's like really
exciting and really fun and then at the
same time like it's not all about riding
big ways it's like most of the time
you're not riding a big wave being a big
wave surfer you ride less big waves than
you know you ride small waves I'm
probably I would say more accurately
more of a small wave surfer because
that's what I surf most of the time
that's just what the ocean produces
right but
um it's sharing all aspects you know the
the UPS the Glorious wins to you know
the the record like the bottom you know
ground level and I I've always been
interested in seeing how people can
build themselves up and if I can share
how I do it I'm not afraid to kind of
share what I've learned along the way so
people can you know maybe skip a step or
two you know and like go to the next
level yeah I think all about going to
the next level and whatever we're doing
yeah well you do such a great job with
it I mean it is you do feel like you're
kind of tagging along for you and
especially through the life of Kai
series like I mean Red Bull media housed
does such an amazing job like that
everything is so high level on a
production level like the cinematography
the editing the music the storytelling
oh it's pretty captivating I mean
everything that I do it it's like
you know I guess I'm the one that gets I
I'm the one doing it but at the same
time like I'm I am where I am today
because I've had so many amazing people
you know starting from the beginning
like my parents you know they're like my
original Heroes uh they help they help
me get on the path that I'm on the
greatest support
um you know and then it's like you know
my friends and family my sponsors but
you know like a team like Rebel media
house being able to you know do
something they allow me to actually go
out and really try to set my level up
and focus and perform and innovate and
do all these things
um because otherwise my brain you know
you only have so much bandwidth in a day
I'd be the one trying to put something
out
much more subpar you know like that I'm
editing at night it's taking away from
you know the actual act that I'm trying
to show everybody so that support and be
able to share it in the best way
possible is like huge and you know as
long as people find it interesting and I
think we'll just keep on doing it yeah
yeah in terms of of casting your gaze
like into the future you know there's
this idea like you're okay you're
innovating on a new level you're doing
things nobody's ever done before you're
doing it in all these different
disciplines
um
but I get the sense that you feel like
you're still in the Starting Gate in
terms of what's possible like we look at
Nazareth oh biggest wave in the world
you know end of conversation no need to
look anywhere else this is where it's
all happening or what you're doing is is
really you know at at the edge of what's
possible but how do you think about that
well it's really fascinating because you
know Nazareth is the current probably
tallest big wave in the world uh and it
was only surfed by Garrett McNamara 11
years ago yeah and you know big wave
surfing has been done since the 60s so
the fact that a giant wave like Nazareth
has been under the noses of every Big
Wave Surfer
in Europe which is well even after it
was discovered people were dismissive of
it for a long time right yeah like it's
just which is bizarre because
well it's not bizarre it's just what I
always find just super interesting is
that like it's a Western Country it's in
you the European Union it's like it's
not like in the middle it's not like
you're going to Africa or something you
know like it's you know it's it's it's
really like why did it take so long to
there's literally a Lookout Point that's
been there there's a literal like
Lighthouse and a giant Harbor I mean
when it comes to big wave surfing it
doesn't get any more convenient you know
we leave the jet skis on the ramp like
on the and you just walk down and get on
the jet ski and in two minutes you're
the harbor is completely flat super
smooth because the trench is so deep and
then I mean that's one reason why they
put the harbor there but then you're
straight out in 80 foot ways like that
in two minutes and it's like what
there's no wave on Earth that's that
convenient that easily accessible but it
took took like you know so long it took
someone like Garrett McNamara to like go
poke around over there and so it makes
me think that you know the hardest thing
about finding a big wave is knowing when
to go you know you can track a storm you
can be that meteorologist be like okay
this foil's gonna hit here but it also
means it's a big wave surfer you're
gonna miss out on the other big waves
that are in that region you know the
standard places like think about how big
the Pacific is and how many islands
there are
um you know you there's a jaw as well
and you know there's this like the waves
are 80 feet there's got to be another
place out there that's as good if better
if not better like I don't doubt it but
it's like you got to go look for it and
you might just get skunked it might take
10 years and then that 10 years of
looking for the mythical better big wave
you know you
you may uh either you may find it you
may never find it but that was 10 years
of not surfing the best big wave in the
world so it's like
I think there's absolutely as big of
waves as nazrier Jaws somewhere right
and I'm just it's just any locals just
hit me up how do you yeah like how do
you begin the hunt you know like how do
you even how do you narrow it down well
I think you know a lot of surfers have
found some of the best waves on planet
Earth via Google Earth you go on Google
Earth and the problem with Google Earth
is like sometimes when the photo is
taken via the sound you have no idea
when that photo yeah well it has the
date the hardest part is like the timing
of it because
it's the you know in surfing it's like
oh you show up to a surf break it's like
you should have been here yesterday it
was twice as big that photo could have
been taken the day before the day after
a giant what if it was just 10 seconds
before the swell came in totally yeah so
it's like but what you end up looking at
is sort of the you you end up trying to
look at how the the the the coastline is
is uh sort of set up you know you look
at kind of like the the
the modeling of um the bottom of the
ocean in that region and you you got to
kind of get pretty Tech you know you
gotta
you almost got to imagine and sometimes
the most perfect setups are there but
they don't get the swell so you get
there's like a window you know it's like
the swells come perfectly to Hawaii
every time and it's like the perfect
distance like everything sort of lines
up
um and so it's like the South Pacific
the southern hemisphere is very active
but the wave Zone tend to get vertically
as tall as say a nazriera Jaws
um but that being said doesn't mean they
don't exist down there it's just like
finding the setup you know it's
it's it's really it's really interesting
um but I think the there's the big waves
out there exist I think maybe bigger
waves you know I don't doubt it but when
we when we were at Surf Ranch you were
talking about
the possibility of exploring the Open
Sea like finding those rogue waves or
just going out you know into the into
the ocean like in the in the really
unchartered areas is that still
something that you think has potential I
think it has total potential I mean you
think about every time I fly in an
airplane I look out the window I'm
flying back to Hawaii from just
California you know 2500 miles I mean
that's like just a short area of how big
the Pacific is or even the Atlantic
right and you know I look down there I'm
like it is so vast it is so big the
ocean in some sort of ways is like a
desert you know like a lot of the life
is kind of towards coastlines or if
there is life it's very very deep but
there's like a lot of like deserty area
and like what could you find in a desert
these big sand dunes you know so there's
there's giant swells out there but like
in order to ride say a rogue wave or to
ride a giant wave
it's it's like you have to be at the
right place the right time and you'd
probably have to find yourself in the
middle of the storm you know and you I
think it's it's totally doable it's
totally possible I think you know the
the first step in the final frontier of
big wave surfing which I think is riding
open ocean monster waves the stuff you
see that big ships are on you know
um you know was going to Cortez bank
which is you know uh one of the Channel
Islands right off here that costs 100
miles off of San Diego
um and that's like a seamount underwater
it's just underwater and the waves get
big and you can't see Coastline anywhere
and it feels like you're in the middle
of the ocean but there has to be other
sea mounts out there that can be like a
shelf like a so it's a shell or part of
the ocean yeah and I think I mean you
know if you had all the time in the
world you would just hop on those big
you know Maritime ships that you know
bring all the goods from you know Asia
over to America ago yeah because you
just sit on it and be like you'd see the
swell to be right and be like okay see
ya and then you'd have to get extracted
somewhere else but I think that's like
the only way to like you almost have to
like wander into it because if you try
to like find it I don't know if you
could ever find it you might get
something but you know it's most of the
time it's like that movie The Perfect
Storm yeah you know yeah you kind of
like end up in the middle of it yeah you
just gotta make use of what's in front
of you sort of thing so every time
you're a movie buff every time you see a
movie where there's waves you've got to
be just thinking oh my God just
realistic should I be which could I ride
this could I not ride it watching
Interstellar it was just driving me nuts
I'm like we gotta go you know
extraterrestrial here like where does
the gravity work a certain way that's
going to create a wave like that yeah
like I mean that way of watching it you
know one of the the characters in that
film and you know spoiler alert dies you
know gets sucked over and I'm like bro
that was you could surf that like the
speed is moving you know and everything
about it like slow moving it doesn't we
don't see it break right no yeah but I
mean I could understand if it's like
5000 feet high and if you've ever been
on the top of a 50-foot wave the amount
of wind could probably send you high
enough where you'd fall like you'd fly
through there and you'd maybe land on
the other side and you know like die
from just falling a severe height but
you know one trick to not getting flung
in the air is at the last five feet of
the wave you dive through the wave and
so you don't feel that atmospheric
pressure on your ears and you know you
you stay in the solid state of water
because water doesn't move you know it's
the energy that's moving in the water
water ends up moving once it breaks you
know it's like this kind of that's why
it turns white and it's like this like
Avalanche effect but the swell the
literal swells out there
um you know it's like
is basically you could stay in the same
place and the swells aren't moving you
the current might move you and the wind
might move you but it's not really the
swells unless they're kind of breaking
so it would just be like an infinite
ride well I think
you'd have a long time to try to figure
out how to get off right you slowly work
your way up or I don't know it's but
yeah watching that watching movies like
that is always fun and most of the time
you know
I think like they see GI waves to make
them look bigger and I'm like oh like
I've seen waves that big you don't need
the CGI almost just got to be in the
right place to film them right you
should do that you know that thing they
do on uh on on GQ where they have you
watch movies and and uh talk about like
how realistic this wave is that wave
this Surfer yeah for sure that'd be
pretty cool is there one movie that that
has nailed it well I've you know not
documented I think I mean culturally
surfing so different that trying to put
it to film is very difficult if you're
trying to have like a wider audience
understand it I don't think it's
impossible but um you know with when it
comes down to just how waves are
approached there's a lot of like looking
into someone's eyes and knowing what
they're thinking sort of thing you know
it's like you know there's like this
unspoken language in a way like and so
that's hard to put to film you kind of
gotta obviously carry the audience and
stuff when it comes to Surf editing you
know it's like 15 different waves put
together and the wave last three minutes
long it doesn't make a lot of sense I
think there's a potential to if a
Hollywood made a movie and was able to
you know put a camera in my hand in
front of a 50 foot wave I could capture
everything practically but the hardest
part about you know making these movies
about big waves is no one's willing to
be put in the spot practically yeah
um and so a lot of times they end up you
know needing CGI and you know CGI just
can't capture water the same way and
just doesn't look right and I think you
need somebody in the editing room or
with the director uh to to like the
nuances you know maybe like when you're
looking at something really like uh
tight it doesn't seem like a big deal
but over the length of a film The Little
nuances kind of like are very striking
and like very obvious to those that look
and I think it would just enhance the
experience of others that don't
um see those nuances they wouldn't
subconsciously they would see it but
maybe like they wouldn't know what
they're seeing it just would be it would
just I don't know what it is but it just
looks so real I can't help but ask you
you mentioned that you're always reading
you got a bunch of books that you're
you're into right now like what are what
are some of the books that you're into
now and and that have kind of impacted
you the most in terms of how you think
about you know how you're pursuing your
lives um I think everyone should read
this book um the war of art not the art
or The Art of War is great too but the
war of art yes Stephen's been a multiple
guest on the show yeah I think that's
like to me that's a book I oh I I should
read probably every couple months it
just keeps I couldn't agree more keeps
you so in tune um and I think it's good
for everyone deals with resistance you
know and I don't know if anyone that
I've ever read or heard speak has put it
clearer to kind of the Indescribable
yeah you know like you know it's hard to
describe an emotion it's hard to
describe a color to somebody if they've
never seen one and that's sort of like
that inner
force that we have it's like uh you how
do you just you can't describe it you
know it's like you know it's there and
he was somehow able to capture it so
that book is I highly recommend it hey
everybody and then another book that I
recently read
um you know I like to read a lot of
fiction too but like on the non-fiction
it's like how to build a car which is
Adrian newey from Red Bull Racing
um that was really interesting he's the
most prolific car designer and it's just
really cool to hear his journey uh from
building going into Formula One and how
he's been able to make the fastest cars
with maybe not the best engines but
aerodynamically and it just was really
interesting I'm So Into formula one that
was like it's a really good read that he
made and uh yeah it was cool yeah that's
cool
um and then just maybe some final
thoughts for people who are kind of
trying to shake things loose in their
mind and find a fresh uh you know
perhaps uncomfortable new approach to
their life to you you know kind of
deepen their relationship with whatever
moves them or you know to get a little
bit more Mastery into their craft like
what is the guidance that you can give
somebody to get out of that comfort zone
purposely doing something that
is uncomfortable like it's like knowing
that because some people equate I think
being uncomfortable
with
um doing something sort of wrong or or
something you know it's like doing
something that you know you should do
for sure but it's like like I'll do it
tomorrow or I'll put it out I'm putting
on my calendar it's like no the moment
you think about you just got to do it
like just then that's the hardest thing
and
um and but I think really important is
having in not everyone's like this but
like goals you know and putting
literally putting it like just somewhere
visually where subconsciously you sort
of see it
um is like a goal that you think is like
too large to obtain but then you break
it down into smaller goals and smaller
until it's so so small that it's like
it's the most easy task like making your
bed in the morning
taking a cold shower I don't know it's
like doing your dishes right after you
eat not just letting it sit in the sink
like that is the discipline that leads
to whatever bigger goal you have and
like that's what I if I if I'm
overwhelmed I just go back to the basics
back to the basics and I remind myself
everything's baby steps baby steps and
then all of a sudden I end up where I
was supposed to go I'm like this isn't
that hard it's because I did all the
right things along the way so you know
most people get stunned by too big of a
goal but that's like that's your future
self's problem yeah and the brightness
the progression you don't you don't drop
into the big wave you you surf the baby
waves and work your way up until the big
wave you know for you you're like I'm
bored by this yeah I know you ride like
when I was nine years old I rode a 15
foot wave face wave and I used to be
really meticulous like how big was that
Dad it was like a 20-foot face wave yes
like I'm stepping it up slowly and so
it's like for me it was in riding waves
to go to the really big stuff it was
like a little bit more a little bit more
a little bit more okay this is I I can't
go there yet but I'm I'm gonna get there
I'm Gonna Keep practicing at this level
and
when I when I'm like hungry I'm gonna be
able to go there but I I didn't give up
I didn't take my foot off the gas even
though I might have like been like
scared and nervous I was still putting
the gas on
and where I was it just maybe took a
little longer to get to where I needed
yeah so allowing yourself time to you
know not really putting a date on the
goal it's good if you feel like that
helps you like like I say in competition
you know trainers Focus like I got this
much time but sometimes it's like having
that goal and and having it just be
there existing and knowing you're always
working towards it but you're not sure
when it's gonna sort of happen and
before you know it all of a sudden you
end up being there like you know a year
goes by you're like I'm already here um
I thought I thought that would take me
10 years you know so it's being having
the ability to play with yourself too
not being locked into like what somebody
told you on the internet or what I'm
telling you now being able to like
constantly adjust like my my training
regimen everything like my I I if I find
something that might be better I'll just
adjust a little bit you're just
constantly adjusting and then eventually
you have like this such a good plan that
works for you for like a couple weeks or
a month you know it like works really
good and then you're like I'm ready to
move on from that I gotta find another
way to sort of like navigate you just
keep adjusting your little plan you know
I always keep a ton of notes on my phone
or reminders you know it's like just
organize it in a way that
yeah it kind of like just kind of cues I
can just look at real quickly like oh
yeah okay like set me on this path right
got it
um your mind goes million miles miles an
hour man you're able to sleep at night
you can shut it down uh it's the hardest
part I'm sure yeah I sleep best probably
on an airplane because I know that's all
I can really do you know I got okay I
gotta get my rest life of Kai season
three is up how many episodes is this
gonna be so we're gonna have a total of
five and uh the next one's about to drop
which is really exciting because it goes
back to you know the last one was that
big shift we sort of talked about me
having a family
um navigating riding really big waves
and kind of like a catch-up for where
I'm at right now and the next episode is
about me going through the Proving
Grounds the mecca of Surfing the North
Shore of Oahu and having the uh like
having the opportunity to surf in the
biggest most prestigious surfing event
in the world the Eddie I cow and you
know trying to accomplish a dream of
riding pipeline the way the most
hardcore pipe Specialists do so you know
it's really it's really cool to see that
episode
um and then you know kind of where it
evolves from there there's a bunch of
other exciting things and I think each
episode keeps getting better and better
so I'm excited for everyone to see it
they drop um once a month and uh and and
they're around 20 minutes long then
what's next for you what's what's top of
mind I mean we're working on a lot of
Innovations here in Los Angeles that I
can't speak on but it could be the game
changing thing that could take my
surfing to another level so I might have
to come back on the show and discuss all
about it once we dial it in but there's
a lot of really cool innovations that
you know I'm really digging into with a
lot of really smart people a lot of
really motivated people and you know
it's about going to the next level so
um doing that for the next month or so
training as hard as I can back home I'm
already you know the next winter swell
uh Jaws or Nazareth or the Northern
Pacific is
um not until probably November of this
year and so I'm training every day like
it's tomorrow and uh then after that you
know I'm taking the family down to
Indonesia and we're gonna reset and go
surf perfect waves and then come back
just you know firing good to go man
awesome well you got an open seat here
when you're ready to come and talk about
your big Manhattan Project I want to
hear all about it maybe you'll tell me
when we turn all this stuff off no for
sure yeah um and uh that was super fun
man thank you appreciate it thank you
cheers